all right uh we have an update for you a
story that we brought you last week a
CBS News investigation that found 400
children of elite Green Berets are
waiting to get into Child Care senior
investigative correspondent Catherine
Herridge spoke to Army families in the
Florida Panhandle who drove up to check
this out three hours a day to drop off
and pick up their kids because their
training camp has no child care center
the closest military facility is 20
miles farther away in Eglin Air Force
Base CBS News found Special Forces
soldiers who say they had to leave the
Army altogether over child care now
here's the good news the secretary of
the army says a new Child Development
Center will be built for families of the
Army's seventh Special Forces Group at
the facility at Camp bull Simmons which
is due in 2025. 20 25 the kids are going
to be free-range before that you're
gonna let them out in the yard
at least there's changes I'm happy
there's changes yeah and when you when
you bring attention to it the things
move and things happen we tend to do
that here at CBS exactly right
very glad about that